[Music]
welcome to my channel
you are watching man carrying thing
today i am carrying
a pancake everyone's doing a newbie tag
a newbie booby tag i'm a newbie boobie i
thought i would get in on the action
i've made a few videos
i think it's my time to properly
introduce myself to
the booktube community hi hello first
question what the [ __ ] am i doing here
that's that's a really rude question the
tone is so unnecessary all right it
really says
why did you start this channel
why not i love watching booktube
channels everyone is
putting out different interesting stuff
it's just a fun environment to be
in and why not start a channel you know
i i talked about it for a while
i think a lot of people talk about it
for a while before they actually [ __ ]
just do it that shia labeouf meme what
you find i think is that there are a lot
of nice people out there supportive
who want to share their thoughts and
obviously
let's be real here it's 20 20. i'm still
in quarantine
there's not a lot of people to talk
about books with except at school and
we're reading you know the canterbury
tales
nothing wrong with the canterbury tales
please don't don't
add me don't [ __ ] at me but you know
i want to talk about
some different stuff brandon sanderson
or whatnot anyways i'm rambling on the
first question all right that was the
first question
what are some fun and unique things you
can bring to booktube
what are you most excited for about this
channel there's a lot i'm excited to
just
i just want to have like a wall of
videos like that i just want to like
click on the videos
thing on my page it's just like a wall
of videos
i also want to branch out and not just
do book book stuff
that's what i hope people will come to
the channel for
is see reviews and talk about books but
i would love to talk about my wrestling
championships
my boxing championships the time i ran
for president
so there's there are things i could talk
about but right now i'm just good
talking about the way of kings
why do you love reading that's a really
really really good question
when you pick up a book you are
transported you are thrown into another
world
i love words i love the sound of words i
love how words
are just like you know that rhythm
and the wordiness of the [ __ ] words
you know a story and the characters and
how there's characters who were like
and there's characters that were like
and how you think something's gonna
happen in the story and then suddenly
it's like
no you don't and then bad stuff happens
and then more bad stuff happens
and then more bad stuff happens you
don't even have to turn
on a [ __ ] television set for it what
book or series got you into reading oh
so many there's a [ __ ] classic book
that is just stands to test the time
called green eggs and ham
that was my jam when i was a little kid
the characters the drama
the ham let's see i read narnia nor i
love narnia
percy jackson uh great oh wait
rolled doll all around great writer
i love roald dahl i still own you know
his books
charlie and the chocolate factory the
bfg matilda
the twits i wrote a sequel to the twits
in like second grade and read it to the
class and i'm pretty sure it was very
graphic
in college i watched a lot of movies but
then i started getting back into reading
and i think that i just i
got interested in in like serious
literature a lot of
joyce and faulkner but then i i started
getting back into
what i really loved reading as when i
was younger which is the fantasy and
science fiction i love h.g
wells and jules verne there's a lot
honestly what question would i ask my
favorite booktubers
daniel green great great booktuber i
would ask
him what his favorite book series is
he's he's he's always a little coy with
it you know and i just want him to tell
his viewers
as a booktuber it's his responsibility
to tell us if he even has a favorite
book series you know because it just
seems like he
isn't particular about anything and just
tell us what your favorite book series
is
what challenges do you think starting a
booktube channel will be the hardest to
overcome
just being consistent life gets in the
way it's a lot of work honestly
there are so many people who are making
really good content who are really new
every single person who posts on like
the booktube reddit i know how hard
and how much effort it takes to get in
and make these videos and edit the
videos and not to mention the reading
that you're doing on top of things
also i think one of the challenges is it
kind of changes your perspective about
reading and what you're going to read in
the future you know like there are books
i want to read that are more obscure but
could i make a video off of it probably
not do i feel like reading oathbringer
right now
you know maybe not i probably want to
read something else but i'm getting
myself to read it so that i can you know
have
stuff to say before rhythm of war so if
you are
looking at it the wrong way if you're
looking at it like oh i need to read for
this video instead of i want to read
this just to read it so
i think that's a potential challenge
honestly what kind of books do you like
to read
i really love to read fantasy and but i
have a really soft spot for
hard science fiction one of my favorite
science fiction series
is the space odyssey series by arthur c
clarke which is
super underrated and under-appreciated i
think i love reading
history just a non-fiction history books
about
the 20th century world war ii civil war
i mean
poetry i'm a huge huge poems fan
poems you know wallace stevens heart
crane
t.s eliot elizabeth bishop james merrill
ar ammons
southern fiction i love eudora welty and
flannery o'connor and william faulkner
of course
i never want to limit myself to genre or
i think that's what i have to say
this is actually a great idea i really
love the newbie tag
when i look at someone's channel and
they're new i always look for the newbie
tag
because i'm thinking okay i just want to
get an idea of who this person is
what kind of stuff they like to read
what their vibe is
hopefully this was somewhat informative
thank you to
everyone who's been been kind to to me
and on the
the other videos and who participating
in in the booktube community
everyone is really kind and sweet and
friendly and warm and everyone wants to
have good conversations about books and
i really love that
thank you for watching you're the real
ones